hey guys and welcome back to the channel
uh I think we finally made it to our
last systems Design Concepts video which
is freaking awesome because I've really
been looking forward to getting to the
next round of videos which is going to
be all the interview questions it's kind
of the main reason that I wanted to redo
everything cuz I just rambled a bunch of
those and never really Drew anything out
cuz I was lazy so uh yeah I'm going to
get to those but unfortunately today I
am super hung over and uh there's a
decent shot I just throw up while
recording this uh so as a result I'm
going to try and get through it as
quickly as possible so let's go ahead
and get to the iPad all righty guys so
today we're going to be talking about
monoliths vers microservices and I'm
going to begin by talking about the
monolith and I have this handy little
note here CU I know many of you might
just think about my junk when I say the
word monolith but no that's not in fact
what I'm talking about what I am talking
about is effectively the idea of having
one kind of you know massive binary that
incorporates all of the functionality of
your application and basically as a
result of having just pretty much one
piece of code that's going to run
everything it basically means that
you're going to deploy it together
you're going to scale it together etc
etc etc so if we were you know to use
Instagram as an example you know we
might have literally just one binary and
within that we would have the ability to
upload files to our service we'd have
the ability to follow other users uh you
know basically serve people ads connect
to third parties deal with metrics and
so of course there are going to be some
pros and cons when designing an
application this way uh the main Pros is
probably just going to be Simplicity if
you just have one repository uh you can
keep all of your dependencies in check
and this is probably less relevant for
something like a systems design
interview but it is an objective upside
of something like a monor repo or a
monolith in general um and then
additionally of course you know if you
just have a smaller application you
don't need a build for that type of
scale why would you split everything out
into different Services you're going to
have a lot less to keep track of if you
just have you know one thing that you're
managing and one thing that actually
needs to be kept working so of course
there are going to be Cons with this
approach as well well which is the
reason that people have begun using
microservices at least in applications
that require tons of scaling so one is
that uh in the case that everything is
in the same repository one bug can
really just take everything down you
know you screw up a dependency chain and
all of a sudden everything is screwed up
and you've got a s 2 on your hands the
other is that you basically can't scale
things out independently so what if for
whatever reason people were uploading
photos a million times more than they
were following one another in the case
of Instagram that may actually be true
you would probably want a lot more
servers devoted to exclusively uploading
things than you would following things
but in the current monolith State
basically every single binary that you
deploy has the ability to do both and
you know you just don't really need that
so let's now go ahead and talk about
microservices because this is going to
allow us to be more efficient with our
resources when we have an application at
huge scale so uh in this case you know
perhaps I'm talking about your private
parts micro but let's go ahead and and
talk about them so in the case of
Instagram I've kind of broken it down
into those five different Services you
know whatever you want to call them
theoretically and basically the gist is
you know if certain things are going to
require more load than others you could
basically go and devote more nodes in
your distributed cluster to actually
running that service specifically the
issue with the monolith is yeah in
theory you can have just a ton of
deployments of that monolith but at the
end of the day all of those services are
going to be stealing resources from what
you actually want to be devoting that
particular deployment to and as a result
decoupling these things within
microservices might make life a little
bit easier so the first thing is that it
doesn't have to be the case that they're
separate repositories but if they are
developed in separate repositories
microservices will allow you to avoid
basically like Global bugs and
additionally teams can kind of develop
independently from one another without
any considerations into you know like
hey we have to use this dependency or we
have to use this technology you're
basically decoupled and you can just
agree on one common interface uh with
which you know to have your
microservices connect basically just
creating apis that's what they're for um
and of course like I mentioned each
service can actually scale independently
which can be more cost efficient and
ultimately allow you to basically get
more usage out of your servers which is
pretty important when you have tons of
users on the cons side though every
single piece can fail because now we
have to keep track of a bunch more stuff
you know for example our ad service can
just have a bug it can go down entirely
and now all of a sudden we have to
monitor you know five different Services
instead of one and be like okay is this
okay is this okay is this okay and then
of course when we will have to deploy
all of these different services to
different places and all of those uh
microservices need different
dependencies and different resources
that can get complicated so to close out
this video I'm going to talk about two
different types of technologies that are
going to greatly help us out with
microservices and actually dealing with
the complications that they introduce
the first is going to be Docker so if
you haven't seen it before the logo
looks like a little bit of a whale but
basically the gist of Docker is this
every single one of our microservices
assuming they have different
Technologies is going to have unique
requirements you know maybe one of them
is in Python maybe one of them is in
Java maybe even within python they just
have different dependencies that they
want and the gist is if I were to just
deploy that to like an actual server
computer then I would have to jump to
that server download all the
dependencies and that's really
complicated and I would have to do it
for every single one of them instead
what Docker does is it basically allows
us to standardize how we are going to
install those dependencies and get our
development environment going
and the way that it does this is through
this usage of a container so think of a
container as this interface right and
the reason I've drawn this out as a
square is because let's imagine every
single computer knows how to run the
square nice and easily but then within
the square you know you can have
anything going on you might have all
different types of dependencies in here
you might have different operating
systems even like different versions of
Linux that you're actually running your
program on and so Docker basically
abstracts away from the actual host that
the container is running on uh the
dependencies and just allows it to run
the the container and so you don't have
to go and install the dependencies
manually on each host which saves a ton
of time additionally another really nice
thing about containers is that as
opposed to something like a virtual
machine you don't necessarily have to
like specify how many resources you need
in advance you know how much memory how
much CPU usage anything like that they
can actually just scale up and down as
more resources are needed and so of
course in a world where we want to cut
as many costs as possible when running
our applications containers are hugely
useful this is going to be critical
when you've got many of them on the same
host which is very common when you are
using something like microservices that
being said great now we have all these
Docker containers but what happens if uh
we need to choose you know for a new
Docker container which host to actually
put it on additionally what happens if a
given Docker container crashes or stops
running or a host goes down how can we
make sure that all of our programs are
running as expected this is where
something called kubernetes comes in so
I think a lot of people when they hear
about Docker and kubernetes think that
they're actually the same thing or you
know there's something that you use one
or you use the other but in reality you
actually tend to use them in conjunction
with one another so kubernetes is pretty
simple we have all these containers and
like I mentioned we don't know where to
actually put them you know all of this
is commodity Hardware so we don't really
care which host it's going on and
additionally we want something to
actually manage failures for us because
otherwise we have to monitor everything
ourselves and that can be really tough
and I had the Eraser out there like an
idiot so basically what kubernetes
allows us to do is specify this concept
of a desired State and kubernetes via
the control plane over here and etcd
which is basically a version of raft
right this is a distributed consensus uh
coordination
service I don't think it actually uses
raft under the hood it probably uses its
own algorithm but uh the point is it's
like zookeeper is keeping track of
basically what systems are up what
systems are down and as a result it can
then send that information over to the
kuet on every single host host one one
could be a VM or it could be a physical
host host 2 and then basically KU uh
kuet will go spin up all of these pods
and each of these pods is effectively
just running a Docker container if a pod
goes down the kuet can notice it and
restart it and similarly if a host goes
down the control plane can notice it and
put that stuff over on a different host
and so by doing this kubernetes makes
things a lot easier to run and manage so
guys let's go ahead and quickly conclude
because we've gone through all of these
great systems Design Concepts and I
would just love to be able to wrap it up
so I can go throw up first off basically
the gist is if you're a massive company
if you're a Google if you're a Facebook
or Microsoft or anything like that
microservices are basically inevitable
you can't really develop every single
thing in the same large binary it's
going to take a forever to compile
forever to deploy and it's going to be
impossible to scale independently with
different pieces that being said because
microservices introduce all of this
additional complexity when it comes to
actually keeping track of and managing
your services Docker and kubernetes or
at least tools similar to those become
very very important Docker like I
mentioned is known as a containerization
tool and kubernetes is going to be more
of like an
orchestration framework at least as far
as I'm aware correct me if I'm wrong and
so to finish off this series I would
love to give two quotes and then we will
go ahead and talk about how they're
relevant here the first is a serious one
and a very good one which is the
premature optimization is the root of
all evil as I spell optimization wrong
bad
that's why Donald n he's a genius and uh
is right about that if you don't really
need microservices you don't have to
actually go and build them out sometimes
a monolith is going to make your life
easier if you're just building for a
personal project and you anticipate
you're going to have a 100 users most
you probably don't need a bunch of
disjoint Services just write it all on
the same app and of course for my
ex-girlfriend yours is perfect the big
ones hurt anyways sometimes you don't
always want to design for scale if you
don't need it and uh this was a
convoluted way of me trying to make a
joke about it but generally guys what I
want to say most is thank you all for
watching this series I hope it's been
helpful I continue to get really really
great feedback from all of you and more
importantly you guys continue to tell me
that it's really benefiting you tons of
you have gotten job offers and I plan on
making an appreciation post for all of
you at some point that I can keep track
of anyways guys have a great rest of
your weekend and I'll see you in the
next one